hi i'm nicholas paul breiswitz the
director of development here at the long
now foundation
and i want to begin tonight's program by
letting you know how much we appreciate
your support for our work
long now is a non-profit organization
and every one of our projects and
programs is entirely funded by members
and donors like you
so thank you for helping us foster
long-term thinking
we believe that civilization scale
challenges call for this kind of
civilization scale thinking
and this has been an especially
challenging year for so many people
and so many organizations including ours
if you're able please consider making a
special donation to our annual
fundraising campaign
you can make an online donation in just
minutes by visiting longnow.org
support by making a tax-deductible gift
to the long now foundation
you'll not only be helping an
organization directly affected by this
civilization scale challenge
but you'll be helping us help everyone
get better at addressing all such
civilization scale challenges
learn more at longnow.org support and
please don't forget to ask your employer
if they have a charitable gift matching
program that could double
or even triple your impact on long-term
thinking thank you again for all your
support
enjoy the seminar hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
we are coming to you from the interval
here in san francisco where james nestor
and i will watch the pre-recorded talk
with you all
and stay on to answer questions
afterward many of you may remember james
from his talk he gave here at the
interval
on the way humans can hold their breath
for tens of minutes at a time
and how that ability came from our
underwater ancestry
in his most recent book james takes us
on a deep dive in a very different way
into the way that we actually breathe
and how that has been affected by modern
agriculture and dentistry
welcome james nester thank you xander
several years ago i came here and spoke
at the long now foundation about the
human connection to the ocean
i talked about magnetoreception this
kind of
natural form of gps that allows sharks
and whales and even humans
to navigate the world without a map i
talked about echolocation and how
cetaceans and people too can actually
see without ever opening our eyes and i
talked about these people
freedivers athletes who had honed the
mammalian dive reflexes that all marine
mammals share
and use them to dive hundreds of feet
deep on a single breath of air
when i asked these free divers how they
could do what they did
they told me it was easy anyone in
reasonable health could do it
all you had to do was master the art of
breathing
it was only by really learning how to
breathe that we could survive
underwater for five six seven eight
minutes
at a time and plummet to such extreme
depths
but these free divers told me something
else they told me that the art of
breathing
extended beyond just deep diving they
told me about
a man who'd been injected with the
bacterial endotoxin
e coli then breathed in a rhythmic
pattern
to stimulate his immune system and
destroy the toxins within minutes
they told me about a woman who'd
overcome decades of autoimmune diseases
by simply changing the way she breathed
and they told me about an
85 year old who'd rediscovered an
ancient
practice to super heat himself and sit
in the snow for
hours without ever getting hypothermia
or frostbite
again using only his breath all of this
sounded insane of course
and i look forward to finding these
charlatans and exposing them
but as i began digging more deeply into
the art of breathing
after i spent months and months reading
through scientific studies and talking
to experts in the field
i discovered that these impossible
stories were actually
true breathing was this extraordinary
tool
we could all use to hack into otherwise
autonomic functions
we could breathe in ways to control our
nervous system shift our brain states
even correct our skelecature each of us
takes in about 30 pounds of air
in and out of our bodies every single
day far more than we eat
and drink the new science of breathing
was showing us
that how we took in all of that air and
how we exhaled it
determined so much of our health our
lifespan
and our human potential how we breathe
was in many ways
as important as what we ate or how much
we exercised
it really was a missing pillar of health
the experts i began working with
told me something else that most of us
are breathing all wrong
now i've been breathing my whole life as
of all of you and i thought i've been
doing it well enough after all i'm still
here
i'm still alive but breathing it turns
out
is not a binary practice it's not just
if we do it or if we don't do it it's
how we do it that's so
important and so many of us have
forgotten how to breathe healthily
about nine percent of the us population
suffers from asthma
about 16 million of us suffer from copd
it's the third
leading cause of death about half of a
snore about 20 percent of us suffer from
nightly exfixiation known as sleep apnea
this list goes on and on
and on these respiratory problems and
other poor breathing habits
can exacerbate or in some cases cause
a laundry list of serious health issues
increased risk of stroke adhd heart
disease there were even links between
poor breathing and metabolic problems
like diabetes
so how did this happen how have humans
become
so divorced from our most basic
biological function
the answers i was told could be found in
ancient
human skulls it turns out that the
pathway
through which humans take in and exhale
air has changed dramatically
in the past few centuries because the
human face
has dramatically changed over the past
few centuries and for the worst
wait what i'd always learned in school
that evolution is a straight line
forward of
progress it's all about survival of the
fittest and darwinism and all that
but as i waded deeper into this research
i learned that
that interpretation of evolution is
wrong
evolution means change and life can
change
for better or for worse take for
instance the concept of natural
selection
natural selection does not produce
organisms
perfectly suited to their environments
instead
natural selection produces a range of
traits
that allow a species to be good enough
to survive
we just need to be good enough to pass
on our genes
to the next generation this helps
explain why humans have grown more obese
why we've grown more myopic
why we've grown more allergic depressed
and fragile
none of these traits are of any benefit
to us they aren't making us stronger or
faster or more resilient
but at the same time they aren't really
stopping us
from breeding harvard anthropologist
daniel lieberman
coined a name for this kind of
regressive change
he called it dis evolution and to a
large extent
this dis-evolution explains why humans
have also become such poor breathers in
other words
we weren't always this way just a few
centuries ago
our mouths and our sinuses and our
airways were vastly different
they allowed us in many ways to breathe
more easily i visited
the museum of archaeology and
anthropology at the university of
pennsylvania to see how we'd changed
the museum contains one of the largest
collections of pre-industrial skulls in
the world
the lead curator there janet monge
showed me a few
dozen different ancient human skulls and
every single one of them
had these powerful jaws these wide faces
and these broad mouths
monge pointed out something else these
skulls had perfect teeth
the skull you see here is not some
rarity
monge told me that she'd never seen a
hunter gather
with crooked teeth not one of them
this was true for all humans all over
the world in india
africa china europe south america and
more the further back
in time you went to 5 000 years old
50 000 years old 150 000 years old you'd
see
even more powerful jaws even wider nasal
passages
even bigger mouths you'd see universally
perfectly straight teeth here's the jaw
of one of the oldest
human skulls it's about 300 000 years
old notice its teeth
perfectly straight even older a million
years ago
our skulls looked like this notice the
huge
nasal cavity here this very wide and
powerful
forward-growing face again straight
teeth
the skull you are seeing now is about 8
000 years old
still this very large powerful jaw
forward growing face
straight teeth now look at how our
skulls look about 2000 years ago
notice how much smaller the jaw is
getting how the face is more narrow
still straight teeth but things are
getting tighter
here is how we look today almost like
another species
very narrow jaw small mouth very slender
face
with a mouth this small teeth no longer
fit
they have to fight for space so they
grow in crooked
ninety percent of us now have some sort
of misalignment
or malocclusion in our teeth this is why
we need extractions and braces and
headgear and all that
our teeth no longer fit in our two small
mouths
there's another problem in having a
mouth that's too small
for its face it's given humans a
different kind of profile
what you're seeing now is a typical
profile of an ancient skull
almost every single skull measured at
the museum of archaeology
and anthropology was found to be ahead
of that perpendicular line
what's called a prognathic profile but
in the last 300
400 years our profiles have been
receding
90 of the human population now has a
face that grows
behind that perpendicular line called a
retrognathic profile
there's a more serious issue to having
this retrognathic profile
than just aesthetics it's shrunken our
airways
a smaller mouth and flatter face means
less room to breathe this is why
so many of us have such a hard time
getting air in and out of our bodies
beyond a few breeds of bulls pugs or
other
highly inbred brachycephalic dogs
modern humans are the only species to
consistently share these traits
we are perhaps the only mammals in the
history
of life on earth to have chronically
crooked teeth
these researchers told me something else
if i didn't believe
any of this all i needed to do was look
at animals in the wild
so of course i did i looked at chimps
they all have perfectly straight teeth i
looked at berberaf mccox
straight teeth dolphins straight teeth i
looked at my mutt of a dog
straight teeth meanwhile this is what
we're stuck with
and if we don't do anything about it we
can end up looking like this
this is how we became the worst
breathers in the animal kingdom
so much for survival of the fittest all
of this brings up
a larger question why why did this
happen to us
and what caused it how could our mouths
shrink and airways become
so obstructed so quickly
i looked to the national institutes of
health for answers
they provided a very clear answer they
said that crooked teeth
were mostly inherited we get them from
our parents
great but that does nothing to explain
why our ancestors
just a few hundred years ago were so
well formed
and why the vast majority of us today
are so messed up
i became pretty obsessed with tracking
this down
and so i wanted to see more skulls
specifically i wanted to see the turning
point
when our faces fell apart on a mass
scale
i wanted to do this to really get my
head around this subject
and in order to do this i needed to get
my hands on some skulls
old ones and lots of them i called some
friends at a foundation
which shall remain nameless the
longmouth foundation
and one of them told me my best chance
of stumbling
upon a large trove of centuries-old
skulls
was to fly to paris and crawl 60 feet
below
the garden of luxembourg down there
within
170 miles of old limestone quarries
was one of the largest graveyards on
earth
six million skeletons dating back from a
couple thousand years
to a couple hundred years so i arrived
in paris and was put in contact
with some freelance urban explorers they
were three women in pantsuits and they
called themselves cataphiles
they'd spent years mapping out the
underground passageways
and claimed to know the location of an
ancient ossuary
filled with a few thousand victims of a
cholera epidemic
that ravaged paris in 1832
this was the time in western history
when small mouths
crooked teeth and obstructed airways
became the norm
throughout paris and much of
industrialized europe
these cataphiles had spent countless
days and nights exploring
where there were no tourists no
descriptive plaques no ropes
no lights and no rules where nothing was
off limits
to be clear this wasn't the most legal
thing i've ever done
after an hour of climbing and digging
through caves and
hallways we reached an enormous pile of
fibulas
ribs and jaws bones all of them human
and skulls hundreds and hundreds of them
i'll admit
i was very much a novice at inspecting
skeletons but there really was
a clear difference in the shape and
symmetry of these skulls from the 1800s
compared to the hunter gatherers and
other ancient
indigenous populations i'd seen before
these were the patient
zeros the modern obstructive face i left
paris
mildly haunted to think that we've been
so perfect
for so long and then just devastated by
this
diss evolution in a relative blink of an
eye
but then again why what was it that
changed in the 1800s
to cause all of this damage i still
didn't know
and i wasn't the first person to wonder
turned out that
dozens of scientists from all over the
world have been asking the same question
for hundreds of years i started pouring
through their research
trying to piece together the story of
our breathing
and how it all went so wrong for much of
the past two millennia
the commonly held belief was that
disease deformities
and other ailments were caused by some
sort of toxic
exposure of some noxious and dirty stuff
infiltrating our bodies and making us
sick
the ancient romans had a name for it
they called it miasma
which meant bad air they believed miasma
emanated from the ground
or from the breath of snakes and other
poisonous animals
if we were exposed to too much of it we
might get a skin disease or bubonic
plague maybe we'd get
leprosy or crooked teeth so human
sickness was
spread through these huge clouds of
poisonous air
this miasma theory stuck around until
around the late 1700s
when a dutch drape shop owner named
anthony van
leeuwenhoek began collecting glass
lenses in a metal tube
constructing the first super powerful
microscope lewinhoke intended to use
this device to inspect the thread he was
selling in his shop
but after a while he got curious began
inspecting other
stuff skin sperm wood pulp
insects and rain water he noticed
something extraordinary
festering within substances were these
little organisms
he called them little animals or
animolecules lemonhoak determined that
yes
our bodies were being infiltrated by
toxins and these substances
were making us sick perhaps even
deforming us
but it wasn't miasma it was these little
evil
animolecules they would later get a
different name
we would call them germs so germ
paranoia
quickly spread throughout europe people
began covering their mouths and their
bodies and their windows
anything to keep these little beasts
away
but no matter how well populations clean
themselves
no matter how many face masks they wore
people kept getting sick and even
stranger
whole populations started getting sick
with new diseases
nobody had ever seen before that few had
even heard of
city dwellers in england were among the
hardest hit in the 16 and 1700s
tens of thousands of children men and
women
began suffering from bendable bones
babies were born
that couldn't sit up or move they
couldn't really hold their heads up or
even crawl
many had deformed jaws and mouths and
had difficulty just getting a breath in
and out one doctor at the time wrote
their bones were flexible like wax that
is rather
liquid so that the flabby and toneless
legs
scarcely sustain the weight of the
superimposed body
this new disease seemed to affect the
rich more than the poor
king charles of england suffered from it
later his daughter would die of it
deformities of the bones became so
common that the condition would be
referred to as
the english disease it would later be
called rickets
the king blamed ricketts on britain's
damp climate but britain's climate
hadn't changed
it was as damp and dreary and awful as
it had always been
what had changed was the english diet
around this time at the dawn of the
industrial age
a whole host of new technologies were
developed to process food more quickly
and cheaply
roller mills and later steam mills
ripped the germ and bran
from wheat leaving only a soft white
flour
meats and fruits and vegetables were
canned and bottled
sugar which was once a prized commodity
of the wealthy
became increasingly common and
inexpensive
for the first time in human history
humans could spend their entire lives
eating
nothing but processed food nothing fresh
nothing raw nothing natural and millions
did
and as they did millions became sick
with new mysterious ailments all the
while the human face
began rapidly deteriorating mouths
shrank
and facial bones grew stunted dental
disease
became common in the incidence of
crooked teeth and jaws
increased tenfold our mouths got so
bad so overcrowded that it became common
to have teeth removed
altogether these maladies affected
not just england but cities throughout
continental europe
really anyone who subsisted on this new
diet
bottled processed industrialized food
meanwhile while all of this awfulness
was going on in continental europe
people living in asia were suffering
from yet another
entirely new and strange disease it too
started with a shortness of breath
then a numbness would take over the
hands and feet
legs would become paralyzed the mouth
would become grossly deformed and teeth
would fall out
this disease was called beriberi named
after the sri lankan senelese words for
week week or i cannot i cannot
said twice to add emphasis by the early
19th century
barry berry was responsible for 35
of all sicknesses in asia a quarter of
the japanese
navy was afflicted and more than a
million people in the region would
die like ricketts it too was believed to
have been spread
by germs but eventually researchers
found the real culprit
once again it was industrialized food
advances in
industrial milling made it quick and
cost effective
to remove the germ and bran from rice
leaving only the starchy white seed
white rice was considered better tasting
and of higher quality
than the brown chewy pre-milled variety
it quickly became the staple of asian
diets
but this white rice was also deforming
people
and making them sick what was making
everyone
so sick wasn't something in the rice it
wasn't
germs it was what the rice was lacking
beriberi was a disease of deficiency
the bran and germ of rice contained
something called thiamin
thiamin would later be called a vital
amine
or vitamin it turned out that rice bran
and germ was a rich source of vitamins
specifically
vitamin b without sufficient levels of b
the muscles and nerves can't function
properly
teeth would become crooked and mouths
would deform
breathing would become labored the exact
ingredient removed during industrial
milling
was vitamin b ricketts was also
a disease of deficiency but the missing
ingredient
causing all of those bendable bones and
mashed mouths
was vitamin d the richest forms of
vitamin d
were found in butter fish oils or suet
all foods that had been removed in the
modern diet
animal bodies can also make vitamin d
but they need regular exposure to
sunlight
in smoggy soot filled london and other
industrialized cities throughout europe
sunlight was in short supply and even
when the sun
did shine modesty required that
populations be covered
from head to toe by the late 1800s and
early 1900s
vitamins b c and d were distributed via
supplements
juices or other nutrient-rich sources
incidents of beriberi throughout asia
quickly plummeted
and practically disappeared as did
ricketts
this was the age of vitamins one of the
greatest revolutions in medical history
this new understanding of nutrition
enabled us
to blunt then almost entirely kill off
so many epidemics which had plagued
humans for hundreds and hundreds of
years
hooray for vitamins and yet something
wasn't
quite right no matter how much orange
juice we drank
no matter how much sun exposure we got
our mouths
just kept getting smaller and smaller
our teeth kept growing more crooked and
our breeding became
more obstructed and labored by the 1920s
a cincinnati-based dentist and
researcher by the name of weston price
was seeing it firsthand each new
generation of kids he treated
were suffering from worse and worse
dental disease and crooked teeth
price's own son would die after a dental
procedure
and still nobody knew why price
dedicated the rest of his life
to finding out but price took a
different approach working alongside a
national geographic researcher and
explorer
price compiled more than 15 000
print photographs more than 4 000 slides
he compiled saliva and food samples and
a library of detailed notes
the same story played out no matter
where he went
societies that had replaced their
traditional diet with industrialized
foods
suffered up to 10 times more cavities
severely crooked teeth
obstructed airways respiratory issues
and overall
poorer health the modern diets were all
the same
white flour white rice jam sweetened
juice canned vegetables and processed
meats
the traditional diets were all different
he traveled to the swiss alps and
visited villages where the locals
ate a diet that consisted almost
entirely of hand-milled bread
and homemade raw milk cheese he traveled
to the scottish isles
where the populations ate mostly fish
and oatmeal
to alaska where communities subsisted
almost entirely
on seal fish and lichen deep inside
melanesia islands he found tribes whose
meals consisted of pumpkins
pawpaws coconut crabs and sometimes
long pigs also known as humans
some cultures ate nothing but meat while
others were mostly vegetarian
some relied primarily on homemade cheese
while others consumed no dairy at all
their teeth were almost always perfect
their mouths were exceptionally wide
their nasal apertures
broad they suffered from few if any
cavities in dental disease
respiratory problems like asthma or even
tuberculosis
price reported were practically
non-existent
while the foods in these diets may have
all varied
they all contained the same high amounts
of vitamins and minerals
from one and a half to 50 times that of
modern diets
all of them price became convinced that
the cause
of our shrinking mouths and obstructive
airways
was deficiencies not just in b
or c or d but of all essential vitamins
vitamins after all often work in
symbiosis
one needs the other to be effective this
explained why supplements could be
useless
unless they were in the presence of
other supplements we needed the full
spectrum
to develop strong bones throughout the
body especially
in the mouth and face by 1939
price published nutrition and physical
degeneration
a 500 page door stop of data
that he collected during his travels it
was a
quote masterpiece of research according
to the canadian
medical association journal ernest
houghton
a harvard professor called it one of the
ethical
pieces of research but others hated it
they couldn't comprehend that these
so-called primitive people had somehow
shared in systems of health
that were far superior than those in the
modern world
in the end price turned out only to be
half right
yes vitamin deficiencies might explain
why so many people
eating industrialized foods were sick
but they couldn't fully explain
the sudden and extreme shrinking of the
mouth
and the blocking of airways that had
swept through modern societies
even if our ancestors consumed a full
spectrum of vitamins and minerals
every day mouths would very likely still
grow
too small what was true for our
ancestors was also true for us
because the problem had less to do with
what we were eating
than how we ate it chewing
it was the constant stress of chewing
that was lacking from our diets
not specifically vitamins a b c or d
95 of the industrialized diet
was soft our ancient ancestors chewed
for hours a day
every day because they chewed so much
their mouths their teeth
their throats and their faces grew to be
wide and strong and pronounced
this larger mouth with straighter teeth
allowed them to breathe more easily
food in industrialized societies was so
processed
that it hardly required any chewing at
all
here's some of the industrialized mush
that i grew up eating
yes of course i had extractions yes of
course i need braces and headgear and
everything else
here's the typical modern american diet
today
cheese sauces baked goods spaghetti
fried roots
it's all soft even what's considered
healthy foods
smoothies yogurt avocados
oatmeal it's all soft healthy chewing
starts in infancy the chewing and
sucking stress required for
breastfeeding
exercises the masseter and other facial
muscles
and stimulates more bone growth allowing
for that
upper palate to drop which leads to
wider airways
tell a few hundred years ago mothers
would breastfeed infants
up to two to four years sometimes even
longer
the more time infants spent chewing and
sucking
the more they'd increase their chances
of breathing better
later on in life with industrialization
came bottle feeding and baby formula
soon in many societies
infants were hardly breastfed at all now
dozens and dozens of studies in the past
two decades have supported this claim
they've shown lower incidence of snoring
and sleep apnea in infants who were
breastfed longer
versus those who were bottle-fed this is
why
so many of the skulls that i'd examined
in the museum of archaeology and
anthropology
that i'd seen at the paris quarries this
is why
they had narrow faces and crooked teeth
it's one of the main reasons why
so many of us today are chronically
stuffed up
why our airways are clogged why we need
sprays and pills and surgery
just to get a fresh breath of air a
couple weeks ago
i was corresponding with dr kevin boyd
he's a pediatric dentist and biological
anthropologist in chicago
boyd has spent years working with dr
marianna evans at the university of
pennsylvania
trying to more deeply understand how our
mouths have changed through the lack of
chewing
and how this has changed our breathing
and our health
they've spent a lot of time examining
fetal skulls
boyd shared with me some of his research
here are some pre-industrial fetal
skulls from around
two to three hundred years ago these
fetuses were from around 18 to 32 weeks
old
you'll notice that profile that pronatic
growth
that pronounced jaw that wider face
now on the left is another
pre-industrial fetal skull
and on the right a very typical modern
skull
at around the same stage of development
notice the difference in profiles
notice on the right that retrognathic
growth the receding jaw
the smaller mouth all of the hallmarks
of a modern obstructed airway
again another modern skull
and another you get the idea
our clogged airways and two small mouths
are now
heritable traits they are getting passed
down
and appear to becoming more pronounced
with every new generation
in other words most modern humans
are screwed right out of the gate this
helps
explain why so many infants snore why
they suffer from sleep apnea
and as a result why so many kids
now are afflicted with adhd and other
chronic health issues
they can't breathe and if they can't
breathe they can't sleep
and if they can't sleep and breathe
properly cognitive
and skeletal development takes a big hit
but i didn't research the ever shrinking
mouth and human disevolution
just to dwell on the negative i wanted
to uncover the core
underlying problems of our breathing so
that we could understand
them so that we could better diagnose
them and
do something about it so we could find
ways of fixing our breathing and
improving our health
and luckily i discovered that so much of
this
disevolution in our mouths and airways
is reversible
there's a sweeping movement in dentistry
right now focused on straightening teeth
while also widening our two small mouths
so many patients with sleep apnea or
snoring even allergies and asthma
have had their issues go away once they
could breathe normally again
by widening the mouth to the size it was
supposed to have been
we can also return to that pronatic
profile as an experiment i wore a device
that stimulated
chewing stress and minimal palatal
expansion
at night in an attempt to fix my own
obstructive breathing
after a year i developed about 15 to 20
percent more space in my airways
now the irony isn't lost on me with all
this how
odd it is today that we are using
industrialized
technologies to restore ourselves to the
way we were supposed to have been
hundreds of thousands of years before
industrialized technologies damaged us
but life is a paradox and what are you
going to do about it not all of us
need such procedures to restore our
breathing for some of us our airways are
just fine
we're suffering from other poor
breathing habits
due to other environmental factors like
polluted air
constant stress or poor posture
correcting these inputs is even more
simple
sitting and standing straight allows
more air to enter our lungs more easily
i found a researcher who'd actually used
breathing
to straighten scoliotic spines
these methods are now being used at
johns hopkins and other institutions
breathing through the nose has
innumerable benefits and today up to 25
to 50 percent of the modern population
habitually breathes through its mouth
this makes us more
susceptible to snoring and sleep apnea
and various respiratory problems mouth
breathing actually impacts
our ability to think the solution here
is even more
simple just shut your mouth
by breathing through the nose we can
filter air heat it
moisten it and condition it we get 20
percent
more oxygen in nasal breaths than we do
equivalent breaths
through the mouth so nasal breathing
also helps
protect us from viruses and other
pathogens which is especially important
today it's really our first line of
defense
with a bit more effort we can learn
breathing practices to hack into our
nervous systems
to heat ourselves and to heal ourselves
even more
some practices have been shown to blunt
or in some
miraculous instances effectively cure a
laundry list
of modern maladies like autoimmune
diseases
asthma and anxiety so none of this
should really
come as too much of a surprise the
ancients have been writing about the
power of breathing for thousands of
years
almost every major religion and dozens
of ancient cultures from the greeks
to the buddhists the hindus to the
native americans celebrated
breathing as a medicine indian yogis
train themselves
to decrease the amount of air they take
in at rest
not increase it they'd adjust the air
coming in through different nostrils to
elicit
different physiological responses the
history of these practices goes back
around 4 000 years the ancient chinese
wrote
seven books entirely focused on
breathing
all the bad things that would happen if
we did it incorrectly
and all the benefits of doing it right
the chinese called their system of
conscious breathing
qigong chi meaning breath gong meaning
work
or put together breath work a quote from
the dao
reads therefore the scholar who
nourishes his life
refines the form and nourishes his
breath isn't this evident
i think it's becoming more evident now
just in the past
decade hundreds and hundreds of studies
are showing
clear measurable benefits of adopting
healthy breathing habits
a quick search on pubmed shows more than
46 000 research studies
on how breathing affects the body and
the mind
this work is being done at top
institutions and the vast majority
of the data is confirming what so many
of the ancients
have said for so many thousands of years
that how we breathe really is a missing
pillar of health
i only hope that this time around we
don't soon forget it
thank you very much for your time
thank you so much james well um as you
can see um since we
recorded this doc in my intro we've had
a shelter in place order
uh come through the bay area and so
we'll be doing the
questions from each of our homes i'd
like to welcome uh
james nester thanks a lot for having me
hey
hey thanks for being here and um and we
also have uh
dr kevin boyd um a chicago chicago
pediatric dentist and a sleep medicine
consultant
uh as well as an assistant professor of
anthropology which i think is such a
great
combo for what you're working on uh at
the university of arkansas i'd love to
welcome in
him into the stream too because i know
we're gonna have a lot of um
medical questions so glad kevin dr boy
i'm here i'm
glad to be here
all right and i'd love to how did you
end up being both a
pediatric dentist sleep medicine
consultant and a anthropologist
really sick drilling teeth and
you know tooth decay is 100 preventable
and didn't want to
make a living you know putting out sugar
fires
and got curious in the origins of tooth
decay
which led me to the origins of
malocclusion you know crooked teeth and
james did a beautiful job
of describing how that happened and they
didn't teach us that in dental school so
i had to go back and almost get a
bachelor's in anthropology
and then it led to uh mentoring phd
research and anthropology and dental
anthropologists
uh so that's all just curiosity and
anger that my own education that's great
[Laughter]
and james do you want to say a little
bit about how you found the researchers
uh like uh like kevin here for sure i
thought i had the whole
breathing field pretty well worked out
uh in non-fiction what you do is you
write a proposal
and i spent about six months writing a
proposal had all the chapters had all
the researchers
and it wasn't until i got much deeper
into this research that
i was missing a huge piece of the puzzle
which is
why are we breathing so poorly it's not
just
anxiety it's not just from the
environment from pollution from
allergens
it's an anatomical problem and once i
discovered that everything really opened
up in a whole
very weird new way as you saw from some
of that research in the talk
cool and i mean i'm really curious i
mean it seems like 90
of the things that you that you kind of
discovered here have happened
in the last 100 to 200 years um
of it's not it's not really human
evolution at that
at that kind of rate it's just um it's
just some
deformations and so do you think in a
few generations or
you know five to ten generations we
could we could get back to our
our straight teeth you know large
airways
well the human body is malleable you
know just as we've
we've injured it uh we can get it back
certainly
i think it's going to take a while i
think that these these things can come
on very quickly but to
help repair them might take a while i
think that we really need to change
how we're eating food other
environmental inputs or oral posture
and so many other things that that
really are contributing to
not only crooked teeth not only poor
breathing
but look at all the other diseases of
civilization out there
you know the top killers in the world
weren't really around
[Music]
uh that huge numbers 200 years ago if
you're looking at diabetes
if if you're looking at heart disease so
many other issues
right and i'm curious um
kevin how how widely accepted is this
into
the the dentistry world in orthodontics
and and medical world where
where do we stand in uh how this is
penetrated
into the field well like like anything
you know i was trained to drill phil and
bill
and orthodontists are trying to you know
um straighten crooked teeth and
teenagers and
they're making i was making a great
living at just meeting the public demand
and
an orthodontist you know the ex the
public expectations
are being met and so we can make good
livings at it but
um like i said i became very discontent
i don't want to do that this is these
are preventable diseases crooked teeth
is preventable
the world health organization has two
initiatives
ending childhood obesity ending
childhood tooth decay what does that
mean that means it can go away in a
generation
you ask the question that's a great
question the and i
proposed um not officially yet
but proposed ending childhood
malocclusion
if it's not as a result or a symptom of
a syndrome
these are preventable things and they
can go away
now they won't completely go away but we
can mitigate
these huge number pandemic numbers
you know of tooth decay obesity and
malocclusion
uh so that that's uh is being met with
resistance by people who are very
comfortable
um making good living at what they were
trained to do and what's the matter with
that i
i don't shame them i just i i broke out
of it i don't know why
i'm sorry can you remind me what male
occlusion is male occlusion is just
poor alignment you know crooked teeth
james was that's that was good you know
it's
crooked teeth poorly aligned jaws and
teeth that's smell occlusion
nice and um and i love the part where
you went into the paris underground to
get a sense of
some of the skulls and you know we had a
great talk uh
from some of those some of those guys a
while back who were
amazing enough to both fly from paris as
well as kind of
led us into their amazing world um but i
wonder if you could say a little bit
more about that trip
yeah uh you know as a journalist i
didn't want to just phone it in and this
was right at the beginning when i had
found
kevin's research and found found
marianna evans research
and i just wanted to sort of more deeply
understand it
and i had the opportunity um through
through some contacts at the long nail
foundation
to do this and i figured i might as well
do it did i learn anything
you know revolutionary you know as far
as research goes no i didn't
but i was curious uh to see it for
myself because
i was even though the proof was all over
the place
i was still doubting it that that why
hadn't i learned this earlier
um and all you have to do if you doubt
it is just look at ancient skulls
and then look in the mirror and look at
the difference so
so you know if this is controversial i i
can't really understand that because
the proof is all over the place and
being down in the paris
uh quarries was just a way to to try to
see that uh face to face you know get a
little more intimate with the subject as
it were
right all right we have some questions
from uh
from the streams um forest pound who
actually works with us on the stream um
he has a three-year-old that is too
young for breathing exercises or is she
um but it should should they be
considering dietary changes like you
know brown rice and things like that at
this point
kevin this is right up your alley
pediatric dentist you take this one
yeah depending on you know where she
lives
um she should establish a dental home we
call it by age one
so she's already been to a dentist uh
even if it's a specialist
depending on where they're trained they
don't know about this
i mean this is only starting to come to
light and enter
uh hopefully the curriculum of dentistry
and how they teach it
so eating hard food you know
i mean james talked about breastfeeding
and weaning
is really important those terms should
never be separated
nursing and weaning breastfeeding and
weaning onto hard unprocessed
foods so right now the question was
about food yes
chew celery carrots apples boom boom
boom
but at three years old that kid is
entering into what i call a geriatrics
patient
i like to get them at two and a half i
can start expanding a kid and
helping the jaw grow but they're going
to look at
if that dad walks into a pediatric
dental office and says look i
i think my kid might need expansion
they'll think he's crazy
uh because this isn't taught in school
yet it will be
uh thankfully for what you're doing this
this might help change it
that's interesting so yeah finding
things to chew on the chewiest foods the
better huh
yeah it's interesting my family always
made fun of me for
only eating raw vegetables uh because
they're from the south and
they boiled everything to death um but i
ended up with straight you know
basically straight teeth and
i never even saw a dentist just because
we didn't really have access to them
until i was
almost in college so my teeth my teeth
kind of may have benefited from that as
well
i wonder if that was it um let's see we
have
david madden from uh one of our feeds uh
who said he loved your talk and that
um he'd really love to hear more about
the the changes that take place
in the womb and what's causing that
uh it seems like you had some of your
slides that were showing that
they haven't even got a chance to chew
yet right
no no that's right and this is this is
something that just absolutely blew my
mind that these are heritable traits so
it brings up the question is
how can this be be happening if this kid
isn't
you know being trained to correct oral
posture or it doesn't have the chance
to breastfeed and this is something that
kevin and i were just talking about a
couple weeks ago
uh gestational apnea and i think that he
would be the the better person to
explain this because it does get
complicated babies do too you know
fetuses
do chew in the womb they chew amniotic
fluid yeah they develop
sucking and swallowing on about mid just
eight you know 20 weeks 20
25 weeks and we have um
ultrasounds of kids and
they're you know you you can't do this
experiment this is not
uh you know a hypothesis that can be
explored
but you can't go back in time and look
at a kid
on an ultrasound 500 years ago but you
can see
stillborn you know fetuses at 20 25
weeks and compare them like james showed
that slide
of you know what really a fairly typical
ultrasound looks like at 20 weeks
so we have proposed
a hypothesis at tufts university dental
school i have an orthodontic resident
that i'm mentoring there
and she is collecting the proposing
you know she's going through the irb
proposal to collect
on kids that present to the orthodontic
clinic
at tufts say they're 12 and they have
you know jaws are too far back like mine
and
getting their ultrasounds from you know
bringing a woman's house wherever they
were born in boston
and comparing what the jaw looked like
at 20 weeks in utero
and maybe there's an algorithm there
that we can predict
uh and this could be something to hey
maybe
if you know you should breastfeed rather
than bottle feed
i i'm very reluctant to talk about
breastfeeding because i'm a guy
and if there's any women that guy he's
never done it
he shouldn't be talking about
breastfeeding so but
you know there's there's research going
on and that's what james you have
really laid the foundation is that there
needs to be
research and data collected there just
isn't now
we can look at ancient fetuses and say
their jaws are forward
well something must have happened what
is it
maybe it's the way the mom's eating the
way she's uh
breathing gestational apnea is something
james brought up
who's heard of gestational apnea you
know it's
it's in the it's in the literature
gestational diabetes gestational
hypertension
aha gestational apnea that could be
part of it we're proposing it and i
can't help
thinking that that perhaps if the mother
has difficulty breathing
if if she is not eating a fully balanced
diet that this can have a downstream
effect
to the feeder if if a mother has has
sleep apnea
you know and there and and is uh
periodically hypoxic
that this could but but again how do you
test this you know sit here
all we want but it's it's a pretty hard
thing to test there's already been an
experiment
that was inadvertently done and that's
called smoking
you know pregnant women uh when they
smoked
their babies were small for gestational
age sometimes pre-term
so in in cigarette companies in the 40s
and 50s were advertising
a win-win the beautiful taste of winston
and a smaller baby easier to liver
to deliver no really i can show you ads
discussions but they've just shown that
they they know the long bones
are smaller when when a woman can't
breathe well during
like smoking but um how about the
jawbones i mean if the long bones if the
legs are small
why wouldn't the jaws be small and
that's kind of what we're going to
explore at tufts
uh about this well it's interesting and
i'm i'm curious like i
i just want to be very clear that sorry
i think we have a little bit of delay
there
um but that um i'm i'm a little bit
curious
about things like chewing gum or that we
have a question from darren online
who's asking um if is there equivalent
of a chew toy to widen passageways like
are there other i know that some things
that you where you chew and you don't
swallow can actually cause stomach
problems like
chewing gum repeatedly but i'm curious
are there
are there kind of some chewing exercises
that we can do
i think there are oral pharyngeal
exercises which have been found to be
very effective
in increasing airway health expanding
airways
they've been studying these exercises
for snoring and sleep apnea and they're
they have a
not a subtle uh changes that that are
occurring in the airway
and what these are are just exercises so
if we're just
eating soft food all the time we're not
exercising this
this big powerful muscle called the
tongue right and so
everything back here can get flabby but
if you start doing these exercises just
like you're doing your curls or push-ups
or whatever you can start to
to influence some fitness and to tone
these areas
so there are several studies i think
four or five studies looking at just
doing these exercises
and their effect to improve your
breathing
interesting um and
um oh hold on uh am and and anne marie
from
uh from one of our streams is asking how
about how do you learn about the
breathing
techniques and where do you suggest that
she start
uh you know uh you start with this
incredible book called breath
no no no you don't need to do that you
can uh
you there there are thousands of years
of of uh of of research
into breathing how to breathe properly
and there are literally hundreds of
different books
i've found in my personal experience the
simplest things
um can be the best um try to focus on
your breath try to breathe slowly
breathe your nose all the time start
with that build that foundation and then
you can get into fancy pranayamas but
it's it's amazing how few people have
proper oral posture
how few people are really breathing
efficiently or in line with their
metabolic needs and so i think you
really start with the simplest steps
here
and then you can build up from there
nice and um and that actually is a good
next question from dan
um who was asking you know what is your
current
uh life and health situation after
learning all this and
you know starting from a path of of
doing breathing exercises and working
your way here and actually i think you
in your book you talk
a bit more about how you kind of you
went to your first your first breathing
class and it kind of freaked you out
yeah it freaked me out and you know
breathing classes are a dime a dozen
here in san francisco you can throw a
whiskey bottle and not hit three or four
uh places like golden breathing classes
so my doctor actually told me to to go
to breathing class because i kept
getting pneumonia year in year out i was
eating the right foods i was sleeping i
was exercising all the time i kept
getting sick i kept having respiratory
problems
and it did freak me out because i i just
started sweating
uh in in a way that that felt completely
unnatural
and so that is one of the things that
really spurred me
to research this more deeply and it took
me years and years to get my head around
it to understand exactly what happens to
the body what happens with the brain
when we breathe in different ways when
we take conscious control of this
biological function
interesting and so and do you feel
healthier now after doing all this
well it makes you a complete neurotic
when you're writing about breathing for
two more years but don't do it people
trust trust me on this
um but after that uh the whole point of
this
is to do it in a certain way to
understand what proper breathing is so
it becomes an unconscious habit you
don't want to walk around like i did
with you know looking at an app or
looking at a notepad
you want to be able to acclimate your
body to
slightly higher levels of co2 to
acclimate your body so that it's very
comfortable breathing through its nose
all the time and very comfortable
breathing slowly but
i you know as as an anecdote
as a subjective experience it absolutely
changed my life and the cat scans show
that
a year before and a year after doing
some just very simple things
massive uh expansion in in my airways i
haven't had a stuffed nose since then
you know that that's been my own
experience i'm not going to say it's
going to work for everyone but
if you look at the science behind this
stuff what happens when you do take
control of your breathing especially if
you're breathing
dysfunctionally or you're a mouth
breather it's not subtle what what
happens
and the science is very clear on all
that
nice and um kevin i'm curious if
like how you know those of us with kids
and you know they do
already have crooked teeth and like now
like do you send them to a dentist can
you find dentists that are
is there a you know a catalog of
dentists that kind of are are
are understanding how to broaden these
air passages and teeth
pallets yeah or how does that work right
now
like something like this it an
orthodontist will call me
pediatric dentist will call me general
dennis will call me look
um i want to help
you know my dental hygienist kid i want
to help my own kid i
i've got patients i don't know how to do
this and
we're we're setting up a coaching
network um
it's through the academy uh it's the
american academy
of physiological aapmd physiological and
medical dentistry aapmd
and we formed this group called the
endeavor and it's a it's a consortium of
about
20 myofunctional therapists which are
speech pathologists and hygienists that
help kids do those chewing exercises
that james talked about
um but also orthodontists pediatric
dentists and general dentists who see
kids and we are coming up
with a way uh to teach dentists
well you know that didn't learn this in
school like i didn't i had to learn this
um after dental school after my
pediatric residency training
and we're forming this consortium of
teaching dentists here's how you present
a case you show me
10 pictures of this four-year-old in
your practice
you describe the child's sleep and
breathing and we have
definite validated risk assessment tools
and then you send them to me or one of
the other
14 members and then we will sort it out
and we'll have a group discussion and we
will help you
um treat this kid you know from afar
and then eventually we need you to take
certain classes that are out there
that you didn't get in dental school but
that's that's where it's going and james
has done more for this movement james is
actually the only
non-doctor clinician uh that's a member
of the endeavor collaborative
um and he's done so much to raise
awareness
and help little kids he has no idea how
many little kids you've already helped
james
well i i will say i had the i had the
easy job here because i am an objective
journalist going into a field that i
knew
zero about i spent several years in it
and talked to people
like you who have been working on this
stuff for decades and decades and
decades so
i was just putting the pieces of this
puzzle together and and one thing that
uh kevin hasn't mentioned yet
is a hundred years ago guess how we were
treating crooked teeth
we were expanding pallets so this is how
it was 10 years old
at when you expand the pallet
you expand the airway larger mouth
larger airway
and and so only in the 1940s did we
start extracting
and using braces and in headgear and and
in europe uh that expansion lasted a lot
longer
so that was a part of the presentation
that that got cut out
but uh but it's all out there and it's
it's all in the scientific literature
and anyone can look it up
nice uh we're gonna welcome uh one of
the founding board members of long now
kevin kelly and the
editor at large and from wired welcome
kevin kelly
hello how are you guys doing good hi
kevin
i'm the second kevin okay yeah a couple
calves
you have dr kevin and you kevin yes
right i am not a doctor
um i i have a question i one of the the
this is for the anthropological side but
um it was always my understanding that
when humanoids invented cooking
the discovery of control of fire and
cooking which
acted as a kind of a secondary outside
stomach that allowed us to
digest nutrition that we could not do
easily
that that actually changed our jaws and
our teeth
in on the historical you know i don't
know whether it's million years or
certainly hundreds of thousands of years
and so i'm wondering if if what we're
seeing now is kind of continuation of
that longer story
uh that's exactly what happened though
800 000 years ago
um i think that's one of the earliest uh
discoveries of the use of controlled
fire
and so having all of this extra energy
available that we save from from chewing
that was released in cooking allowed us
to grow a larger brain
and that brain needed space so it took
that space
from the front of the face and our faces
started growing
flatter okay and our teeth start getting
smaller and our jaws start getting
smaller but these changes happen
over tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of years
and we acclimated to these changes just
fine so according to the skeletal record
we were breathing just fine
so uh what has happened to modern humans
in the past
few hundred years this happens so quick
we have not been able to cat
right so our mouths are way too small
our teeth are okay
our ways are but but the the general
trend though is a continuation of that
trend right of reducing the size of the
jaws and the teeth so you could kind of
say that it's sort of like
a continuation of that same process
of modernization and eating
cooked food that's like saying obesity
is a continuation and we're just going
to keep getting fatter
and you know i i know i know exactly
what you meant there
but no we have to stop this trend i i
mean
narrowing jaws and obesity there
one is um over abundance and too big and
the other one
is too small and under um
you know uh achievement if you will it's
just
no it's a trend that has to stop but
yeah if it continues
it's it's disaster so um if you take the
kind of again the long view and this
time going
not the long past but the long future if
you imagine
uh some scenarios for the next hundred
years
um what would our jaws
look like in a hundred years do we
imagine
that they would be the same size they
were
in the last couple thousand years would
we like to
have we identified any genes of our jaw
size and teeth that we might want to
engineer
to make larger or i mean like if we
could imagine us taking control of this
what would you imagine we might do you
could have more than one scenario but
what would be some of the things
we might do in a hundred years regarding
our draws and tea size
yeah uh you know go back to eating whole
foods
is is the first thing that that you
should do i mean we want to live up to
our epigenetic potential
right we don't want our mouths to
continue growing smaller and smaller and
smaller and their teeth to be
getting more and more crooked so jeans
can be turned on they can be turned off
so if we see this dis evolution
happening right now if we've taken a
sharp
left turn if our airways have taken a
sharp left turn we can work to help
restore that i've found even if you're
in middle age you can show improvement
to your palate you can show improvement
to your airway
so uh the the body is plastic i was just
talking to someone about
neuroplasticity i think we should be
talking about breathing plasticity or
mouth plasticity
uh the human body can be changed for the
better or for the worse depending on
what environment
environmental inputs are given to it
and so kevin do you have an idea of what
might happen over 100 years
again what some of the possibilities
would be the the genes
you know there there isn't a gene that
or as a suite of genes you know there's
no there's just not one gene one trait
it doesn't work that way very seldom
there are a few things like that
is that there's groups of genes on
individual chromosomes that interact
with genes on other chromosomes
in concert interacting with the
environment it's epigenetics
so you can have a group of genes
that will code for type 2 diabetes that
never expresses itself
if the person lives a healthy lifestyle
you can you can carry those genes but
they just won't turn on
unless you subject it to an environment
and it's the same thing with
malocclusion
so in the next hundred years you know
people are going to wake up i mean you
know james
james has an acumen for anthropology and
natural selection
that rivals like hugely rivals
most health care professionals we don't
have to learn about how natural
selection works
when we're in medical and dental school
you know we deal with proximate cause
you got a fever take an aspirin
um well maybe we should find out what
pathogen is causing
causing the fever and james has really
grasped such an understanding and an
appreciation
of how important it is to understand the
evolutionary explanation
rather than the proximate cause of
disease so
getting to your question like well is it
a linear projection in a hundred years
like if the jaws have gotten this small
and a hundred years what's it gonna be
a hundred years from now and is it it
won't be linear i
i think if it were that it would
contribute to human extinction
and and i just don't think people like
to think that humans can go extinct
a lot of that is religious but we can
like every other species on earth 99.9
of everything that's ever been born from
the first bacteria
4 billion years ago everything's extinct
except a few things that are here now
and that's where we're headed if we
don't get you know this and other things
breathing properly through the nose and
having jaws that are conducive to that
and taking in adequate nutrition we're
smart we have a big frontal cortex
lucky for us we better start using it
nice well we're going to wrap this up
and i'd love to thank actually both
kevin's
dr kevin boyd and kevin kelly um
and we'll uh we'll just go to james and
i as we i give
the last couple questions um
thank you guys um james i'm
i think uh kev dr kevin boyd did a great
job of pointing out how
bad i think um many times when people
are
siloed in their professions they're
really bad at kind of connecting the
dots and
and we've seen you know over and over
again with some of our like all species
initiatives and the language initiatives
that
uh it's rare that people can you know
they they actually kind of get
uh academia really rewards
specialization
and doesn't really reward generalization
and so the work that you've done here
and kind of
helping these people kind of connect
with each other i suspect you even
in your research you help them find each
other uh to some extent
uh in what they're doing so i think it's
it's it was a great effort
and um and so cool to see and so i'm
really curious as to what your next
project is
i have another book idea but the idea of
uh you know sitting in a
in a room for three years and riding
alone uh just kind of makes me queasy
so i'm gonna just uh continue talking
about uh breathing for a little while
longer i'm still excited about the
subject every time i talk to kevin i get
all amped up
and i wanna get this word out but
hopefully we're gonna bring
um this and and some of the other
subjects i've talked about at long now
uh into a different medium
uh perhaps into a a video
kind of series and so um i'm looking
into that but
you know in about a year i think i'll be
it'll be time for
to sink back into a new project
well we're all stuck in rooms in front
of our computer screens now so
we're all writers now but uh yeah
we've all got beards now everybody yeah
nice well i want to thank you for your
book and i do want to say like that that
you did a great job of kind of going
down a much more long now angle of what
your book is and there's so many more
great stories in your book and i really
want to encourage people to read it it
reads really well
and i was i've been listening to it or i
listened i ended up listening to all of
it and you do a great job reading your
book so it's great to hear your voice
uh in the audio version which i i
enjoyed
so thank you so much for joining us and
um thank you all for joining the live
stream
and look forward to um i think we're
coming up on our last event of the year
we'll be next will be uh lost landscapes
um which will not be one of our normal
events but uh we'll be back on in
january
and hopefully on the other side of 2020.
thank you all thank you